ich finde es handelt sich um subventions
literatur die nicht wirklich was mit dem
leben zu tun hatten die worte versagen
jahr will sie erst mal was gutes dazu
sagen oder soll ich erst mal sagen was
ich daran hochgradig bedenklich für die
schildkröten soldat von melinda nadj
abonji das habe ich gelesen und habe auf
jeder seite gedacht philipp wird das
hassen philipp wirte fassen also ich
finde sprachlich sehr präzise sehr
schöne bilder sehr feinsinnig mit
sprache operieren okay ich habe neulich
gehört von einem neuronalen netzwerk das
5000 bach choral kantaten am tag
komponiert ich möchte sagen in zwei drei
jahren sind vielleicht so weit dass wir
ein algorithmus haben selbst werden die
5000 von solchen romanen am tag
hervorbringt die alle so sind wie dieses
buch schildkröten soldat ist die
geschichte eines serbischen jungen
mannes der vom motorrad fällt und dann
epilepsie bekommt und damit eher ein
mann wird wird er von seiner familie zum
militär geschickt dieses militär macht
ihn letztendlich komplett kaputt das ist
eine gefühlsduseligen reihung von zähnen
eine szenische reihe mein argument ist
dass sie es schafft dass man diese
erbarmungslosigkeit des militärs zu
spüren bekommt und dass man anteil nimmt
an dem schicksal dieses protagonisten
der von allen zerstört wird nach außen
hin hat der große sprachschwierigkeiten
aber nach innen hin hat er eben einen
wahnsinnig großes reflexionsvermögen
hatte das ist der skandal dass selbst
anlässe wie der balkankrieg um den es
vorgeblich geht werden zu kulissen der
innerlichkeit hier da kannst du jetzt
wirklich gar nichts sagen doch habe ich
gerade du hast nicht höre ich dass ich
liebe dich aber du hast nicht recht ich
habe selbst recht aber in diesem fall
glaube ich bin sind die argumente auf
meiner seite
wie gesagt ein selbstlernen der
algorithmus den mann mit den vorgaben
füttert schafft 5000 davon am tag ich
meine dann brauchen wir alle gar keine
bücher mehr zu lesen und zu schreiben
und und braucht nicht mehr zu
komponieren
doch komponiert auch nicht mehr hh
[Gelächter]